- I do freestyle rap.
That is rap made up on the spot
based entirely on your suggestions.
We're going to get you guys involved.
I want you guys to be creative.
The best suggestion I ever
had was a German man who said
"a day in the life of
an Aztec high priest."
So try and beat Klaus from Hamburg, okay.
I want you to do better than that.
We'll get five suggestions.
If you've got one, all you
gotta do, put your hand up,
my microphone man is
going to run over to you,
we'll get the suggestion. Microphone man,
bring it down to this
handsome chap in the front.
Lovely. Hey, what would you
like a rap about my friend?
- I would like you to rap
about Apogee Playground.
- I beg your pardon you, why
did you suddenly go French?
When you said that you were like,
"Yeah, I'd like you to rap about
(mumbling)
What?
- Yep, It's called Apogee Playground.
- Apogee Playground.
Is that something that
you're involved with?
- Exactly.
- That is the most
disgraceful, self-promoting,
startup attitude I've
ever heard of. Well done.
- Thank you.
- No one else is going
to be allowed to do that.
You're the only per, pray tell
what is Apogee Playground?
Keep it short. This is not a pitch.
- We are asking people to
turn their work into play.
- Turn work into play
with Apogee Playground.
If you post this online, you
owe me a lot of money, okay?
- Yes I do.
- Apogee Playground, turn work into play.
Let's get our second suggestion.
Hand up if you got one.
Oh yeah. Right behind you. Perfect.
So, what would you like a rap about?
- Baby influencers.
- Baby influencers. Thank
you. That's perfect.
Let's get our third suggestion
from the lady over there.
Apogee Playground, baby influences.
Yes. Go for it.
- Circular economy.
Circular.
- A circular pyramid?
- Economy
- Oh, economy.
I thought you said a
circular pyramid. I was like,
she's trying to catch me out.
I also love that you
stood up for that one.
And I was like, is she going to sing?
Is she going to take over this?
A circular economy, Apogee
Playground, baby influencers.
People on this side,
what would you like a rap about?
My man here, busting
out of the shirt? Yes.
What would you like to rap about?
- Fitness.
- Fitness, Okay. What, what's
your particular favorite type
of fitness?
- Any kind.
- You're the most boring
answer ever. Yeah okay.
I'm not giving you my secrets, Chris.
So you've got to work hard
to get guns like these.
Let's get our final suggestion.
Yes, right there. Right by you.
- Hi, crypto please.
- Crypto, erm, be more specific.
- Hmm, Crypto trading? Does that help?
- Okay. No that's fine.
Yeah. Cool trading.
Okay. Crypto trading,
fitness, baby influencers,
a circular economy, an Apogee Playground,
which aims to turn work in to play.
This, lovely people,
if we can drop that beat
good sir, is a freestyle.
As I said, made up on the spot
based entirely on suggestions.
Not written, not prepared, not rehearsed,
never to be repeated, and do not worry.
It will not be anywhere
near as atrociously,
embarrassingly, toe curling bad
as you're expecting a
privately educated middle-class
white boy to be.
A little bit more on the
beat there my friend.
Let's do this.
♪ The base kicks and we slay that sound. ♪
♪ I like the guy wants to
clicks on the playground ♪
♪ at the top, that's the
Apogee, I rap so naturally ♪
♪ I'm basically giving
you an ad for free. ♪
♪ You've got to make sure
you do it everyday. ♪
♪ We're going to turn
that work into play. ♪
♪ Admittedly, it's slightly
mental in the mind, why? ♪
♪ You should produce
not just leisure time. ♪
♪ I'm going to move on, it's how we do. ♪
♪ I want to be circular,
like number two. ♪
♪ I talk about the economy.
I'm going to do it properly. ♪
♪ If I got the cash and you
want to get it off of me, ♪
♪ you gotta make sure you keep interest. ♪
♪ I spend that gold and
reinvest it goes round, ♪
♪ keep it like a closed loop. ♪
♪ Like I'm recycling
things here, I ask you. ♪
♪ This guy, check the arms on him. ♪
♪ Always slayin pump iron
when he's there at the gym. ♪
♪ I ask for explanation,
can you charm me? ♪
♪ He's like ya, I pump iron like Arnie. ♪
♪ Arnold Schwarzenegger. And
I impress all of the ladies. ♪
♪ When I do the fitness, I go
there letting my guns swell. ♪
♪ I like to pump all of that
wisdumbbells, ah so hard. ♪
♪ I go berserk I like
to twerk in the mirror ♪
♪ when I clean and jerk. ♪
♪ Look at these, I'm a big bro. ♪
♪ Probably investing in
crypto. I see that body. ♪
♪ It's not so strange. ♪
♪ I like the shape he be
puttin it on the exchange. ♪
♪ Maybe get the Bitcoin
ethereal Mor Doge ♪
♪ If you invest wisely,
then it will grow. ♪
♪ But the last one, I like it. ♪
♪ Oh you crazy. Talk about
this I'm an influencer baby. ♪
♪ I'm on the insta, taking the selfie. ♪
♪ I'm still in diapers, but
I'm gonna get wealthy. ♪
♪ I get there, I make those moves. ♪
♪ I be making that cash
while I suckle from a boob. ♪
♪ It might seem, kind of strange, ♪
♪ to be an infant that
still make that change. ♪
♪ I say, mum, I say dad, can ya
buy me a pacifier hashtag ad ♪
♪ You need to place it. That's the plan. ♪
♪ I've never seen a baby on
Instagram. There we go. ♪
(hip-hop music continues)
(crowd applause and cheering)